our truth on men women and money fifty
common money mistakes and how to fix
them
he joins us this morning Kevin thanks
for joining us during a brave man the
look on that woman's face I think she
was a stand-in for many who thought huh
you're defending this you know I think
we vilify the creation of wealth we
vilify capitalism it's become very
unpopular to talk about successful
people but you know I what I'm trying to
say is it's not fantastic to be poor and
I don't like disparity in wealth or or
poverty there's all bad things but let's
celebrate the facts all right if you
look back at last 30 years 42 percent of
the world's population was in desperate
poverty today it's 17 percent thank you
capitalism thank you that's what made
that happen all right if you go back to
1970 percent of the world's population
was illiterate
today it's 17 percent thank you
capitalism thank you let's celebrate
what's working and the metrics show us
and the numbers show us that our system
works so let's not vilify it right
people become consumed with envy however
when they think they can't become rich
the system works as long as people see a
plausible path to success but if they
think that that plot that path is
blocked and then they get resentful and
your society comes it becomes unstable
no it's not blocked that's not true the
American Dream is alive and well you can
see the evidence of it look at the
success of Shark Tank people starting
ideas and businesses creating wealth
grew book last Friday they became
millionaires in a week as a result of
their product getting on the show
there's every evidence everywhere that
what we do and what works in America
capitalism creates wealth and those
people pay taxes yes 30 to 50 percent
depending where they are and that goes
back into the system to support all
kinds of initiatives including helping
people that were there in poverty it's
so funny you are from Canada yes
originally you must be the 5th Canadian
I've met in the United States reminding
America that the market works is this a
remarkable time there's no place in the
world like America when I started my
business I wanted to come here to create
it and grow it I was in a jurisdiction
Ontario in the mid 90s where they had a
socialist government I had to leave it
was an oppressed environment you
couldn't build a business their taxes
were crazy nobody wanted to give me
money I moved to Boston when I wanted to
wealth and higher 10,000 people around
the world I came to America this is
where you create business this is the
heartbeat of creation of wealth and
capitalism and any time someone tries to
change that they're making a huge
mistake
calling business leaders fat cats and
saying that this is a bad thing is
unamerican this is the place where
everybody around the world wants to come
to be successful what's wrong with that
you think that's changing oh yeah the
tonality today is unhealthy in my view
you know when I came to Boston Bain
Capital was not a swear word they gave
me two hundred million dollars to help
me build my business globally and hire
thousands of people and pay millions in
taxes why in the world would we vilify
that I think something's really gone
awry and I think it'll come back at some
point but right now we should be talking
about creating jobs through small
business there's six million small
businesses today in America we ask
ourselves why there's not employment
over seven percent because we made it so
difficult for them through regulations
last year 2,800 new federal regulation
yeah who can even comply with that we're
competing with the Chinese now we're in
a football game we've gotta make it
easier it's crazy
kevin O'Leary author of cold hard truth
on men women and money 50 common
mistakes money mistakes and how to fix
them great book thank you really
interesting thank you you're a brave man
to say that I appreciate take care